someone asked about indecisiveness no I
was crippled for indecis you don't want
to lose you want your narrative if you
don't lose then you can keep having a
narrative that you're as good as me and
Ela musk and like you can keep playing
that game the second you do you have to
accept it's why I'm so pumped to get
older like when I tell you one of the
most significant videos I'm ever going
to make in my life is when someone else
buys the jet because the video is going
to be like she did it
better I just don't want you to regret
you're going to be very unhappy in your
70s if you don't do but this is nothing
right now when you're 70 and 80 and you
just kid the whole time don't be scared
you got so much support I just don't
want you to worry about anybody else's
opinion starting with your
own